the Apple pencil is special whether you
like it is a different question some
people don't like its plasticky feel
maybe you don't like the super hard tip
but it's definitely special when you use
the pencil there's no lag at Baia it's
really like you're putting ink on paper
it does a better job than almost any
other stylist ever and sensing and
responding to pressure or angle you turn
this thing on its side and rub and it
feels like you're shaving with an actual
pencil
there's so little latency because apples
actually retrieving data from the pencil
at twice the speed it would if you touch
the screen using your finger or with
another stylus and it's software can
even predict where you're going to draw
and because it's refreshing so fast
you'll never notice if the guess is
wrong the iPad pro can measure the angle
of the pencil how hard it's pressing and
more all in real time you just can't get
that kind of data out of any other
stylus even small things like being able
to charge the pencil through the iPad
pros lightning port make a huge
difference the Apple pencil cost $99 and
it feels like one of the best stylus is
ever not because it's a great piece of
hardware but because Apple can make it
do things no other stylus can it's
definitely special